Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Die Ligatur ist wieder zurück. Wir blicken auf den europäischen Männerfußball. Da ist so einiges passiert. Wir werden es aufarbeiten in eurem Lieblingsformat hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 257. Ich begrüße euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid und schön, dass auch sie alle wieder mit dabei sind. Ich begrüße jetzt mal Nils Kern, hallo Nils. Hola, buenos días.
Schön, mal wieder dabei zu sein.
Hi, da bist du laut auf einmal. Das war im Vorgespräch aber nicht so, aber schön, dass du hier bist. Das ist wahrscheinlich die Euphorie, die hattest du vorhin. Na ja, gut, da werden wir gleich darüber sprechen. Dann begrüße ich Jogi Hebel. Hallo Jogi. Und David Frogier de Ponlevoy ist wieder dabei. Hallo. Und neben mir sitzt Christian Bernhard. Hallo Christian. Hallo, schönen guten Tag. Wir legen gleich los. Ich möchte aber vorher noch zwei Ankündigungen machen. Zum einen, der Rasenfunk finanziert sich ausschließlich über die Crowd, also über euch Höhrende da draußen. Bitte tut das auch, rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Vielleicht gibt es ja auch Leute da draußen, die nur die Ligatur hören, würde ich natürlich streng verurteilen. Aber andererseits darf jeder leben, wie er leben mag. Aber was ich auch sagen wollte, es empfiehlt doch die Ligatur gerne weiter. Also inzwischen haben wir jetzt ja eine Regelmäßigkeit gefunden, die wir auch versuchen beizuhalten. Alle zwei Wochen gibt es die Ligatur und ich habe das Gefühl, dass noch gar nicht so viele mitbekommen haben, dass es das jetzt im Rasenfunk auch wirklich regelmäßig und verlässlich gibt. Also empfehlt doch mal bitte den Rasenfunk weiter an diejenigen Freunde und Freundinnen von euch, die das interessieren könnte. Und dann habe ich noch eine Nachricht an alle Leute, die aus dem Großraum Ulm kommen. Ich beziehe da Stuttgart mit ein, denn da gibt es bisher noch keine Lesung. Ich werde am 20. April, das ist genau nächste Woche, werde ich in Ulm lesen, im Roxy. Da stand schon dritte Wahl auf der Bühne. Finde ich lustig, dass ich mir eine Bühne mit ihnen teile. Natürlich aus meinem Buch aus Liebe zum Spiel. Deshalb wird es den Zweitliga-Kurzpass nächste Woche auch schon am Dienstag geben. Denn am Donnerstag bin ich ja dann – na, wo bin ich da? in Ulm. So ist es richtig. Das reicht mit der Vorrede. Jetzt beginnen wir mit der Sendung. Und wir haben den Vorteil, dass wir einen Champions-League-Abend hinter uns haben. Und nachdem der Nils schon so super, super selbstbewusst hier angekündigt hat, dass Real nach seinem 2 zu 0 gegen Chelsea da im Auftaktspiel weiter ist, geht an dich die erste Frage. Nils, wie fandest du die bisherigen Partien, die wir so sehen durften im Viertelfinale?
Auch im Viertelfinale doch recht unterhaltend. Hier unterhand ein paar Überraschungen, dass die Bayern da mit drei Toren untergehen. War vielleicht um ein Tor zu hoch, aber ich habe ja da mehr den Fokus auf den spanischen Fußball. Und da ist nur noch ein Teilnehmer mit dabei. Das war Real Madrid und ich hatte schon vorhin mit dem Jogi kurz geredet. Ihnen hat jetzt Chelsea auch nicht so sehr überrascht und viel Hoffnung ist da fürs Rückspiel nicht mehr dabei. Ja, nur 2-0 gewonnen im Hinspiel, nur in Anführungszeichen. Aber ich glaube, da war der Unterschied dann doch zu groß und es gibt zu viele Probleme bei Chelsea. Also da dürfte Real Madrid mal wieder ins Halbfinale einziehen. Und das Duell gegen die Bayern würde mich schon auch mehr interessieren, den Klassiker. Aber vielleicht wird es dann doch wieder ein spanisch-englisches Duell.
Der Klassiker, was jetzt inzwischen alles schon der Klassiker ist. Der ist doch auch nicht der europäische Klassiker. Naja, egal, egal, egal, egal. Aber ich weiß, dass Jogi ja sowieso über das Debüt von Frank Lampard sprechen wollte. Der ist ja neuer Chelsea-Trainer für alle diejenigen, die das nicht mitbekommen haben da draußen. Jogi, was ist denn jetzt nach diesem 0 zu 2 gegen Real, das ja auch in Unterzahl erzielt wurde? Also ab der 59. Minute nur noch zu 10 die Londoner und dann nur noch ein Tor kassiert durch Asensio. Also man kann es ja sicherlich auch positiv drehen, wie es ja auch manchmal passiert im Fußball, wie ich gehört habe.
Ja, also ich bin kein großer Freund von dieser Verpflichtung, wenn ich ehrlich bin, weil wir wissen auch so aus einer sehr, sehr guten Quelle, dass das jetzt keine sportliche Entscheidung war. Pro Frank Lampard, sondern eher so eine PR-Geschichte. Die Leute vor Ort wissen, dass sie momentan einfach Unruhe haben, dass ihnen so ein wenig die Fans davondriften, aber sicher weil einfach zu viele wilde Entscheidungen getroffen worden sind. Sie wussten auch, dass sie mit den Trainerkandidaten jetzt nicht gleich einig werden würden. Sehr rekognitiv. Deswegen hat man dann irgendwann gesagt, na gut, dann müssen wir jetzt jemanden installieren. Bruno, der ja zwischendrin da war, der wollte es nicht machen und sonst hat man keinen gefunden. Innerhalb des Vereins. Deswegen dachten wir uns irgendwann mal, okay, wir müssen jemanden von extern holen. Und dann muss wohl jemand mit Frank Lampard gekommen sein, aber nicht von der sportlichen Leitung, sondern jemand anderes. Wer genau ist uns nicht bekannt, ist nicht so ganz klar. Es gibt ja das Gerücht, dass es James Gordon war. Das ist wohl widerlegt. Also ganz so wild soll es dann doch nicht abgelaufen sein.
Okay, also das ist quasi das Zustandekommen des Wechsels. Aber jetzt mal auf dieses 0 zu 2 bezogen. Kann man denn irgendwas spielerisches erkennen? Denn es wäre jetzt ja auch ungerecht Frank Lampard gegenüber, auch wenn er jetzt nicht die großen Erfolge bisher als Trainer hatte. Aber wäre ja auch ein bisschen respektlos jetzt von uns, wenn wir jetzt das Sportliche gar nicht mit einbeziehen. Er kann ja nichts dafür, wie er vielleicht verpflichtet wurde.
Ja genau, er hat ja auch nicht viel Zeit gehabt. Das muss man auch sagen. Also ich muss zugeben, ich habe jetzt nicht mega viel gesehen, weil wir gestern essen waren und ich habe es immer so im Augenwinkel gesehen. Aber allzu viel kann er ja auch in dieser Zeit noch nicht machen. Also vor diesem Spiel ja auch, da liegt so viel im Argen. Die Mannschaft ist ja sehr, sehr wild zusammengestellt. Haben wir auch schon vorher gerade drüber gesprochen mit Nils. Es ist sehr, sehr wild zusammengestellt. Er hat da nicht wirklich viel Zeit gehabt, da irgendwie reinzukommen. Die Offensive läuft gar nicht. 31 Tore in der Liga ist eine Katastrophe. Er hat es nicht einfach, aber wir wissen auch aus seinen vorherigen Stationen, der große Denker ist er jetzt auch nicht gewesen, was das betrifft.
Aber das mit der Offensive ist, glaube ich, ein wichtiger Punkt, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe. Vier Spiele jetzt ohne Tor. Da wird ja bei Nils der Puls hochgegangen sein, oder wenn der João Felix einfach mal zentral durch ist. Und mit einfach mal zentral durch meine ich einfach mal zentral durch. Der war mit zwei Metern Vorsprung, war er weg. Dann war der Vorsprung irgendwann auch weg und dann war der Schuss auch nicht so platziert. Und eine ähnliche Chance gab es kurz danach noch mal. Also es gab ja die Momente, aber die Torgefahr und Effizienz im Verwerten der Torschance nicht gefehlt.
Ja, ich sag mal Real Madrid oder Luca Modric in dem Fall mit dem Wahlverlust. Wollte es ein bisschen spannend machen, so von wegen kommen, wir lassen euch auch mal eine Chance-Idee vorlegen, dann legen wir los. In dem Fall dann eben Felix nicht getroffen, wurde auch noch von Milly Tauer eingeholt, also der hat ihm noch ein paar Meter wieder da abgenommen. Ja, die individuelle Qualität ist natürlich bei Chelsea trotzdem hoch, aber man merkt, da ist auch wenig irgendwie Team-Chemie da, viele sinkende Köpfe, was man in Bernabéu so gesehen hat, und deswegen dann auch, ja, da wenig Hoffnung fürs Rückspiel. Immerhin Mount hätte er in der Schlussphase ja noch, 92. Minute, noch für das 2-1 sorgen können, das wurde dann von Rüdiger weggegrätscht, also ja, das Ergebnis ist das einzige, wo Chelsea noch Hoffnung haben kann, dass es jetzt nur 2-0 oder fast 2-1 ausgegangen wäre. Real Madrid hätte ja auch noch gut das dritte, viertem machen können. Aber ja, jetzt so viele Spiele ohne eigenen Treffer und irgendwie egal, wer das spielt. Immerhin Lampard hat ja ein bisschen was probiert, im Möglichen 5-3-2 ohne echt ein neuner. Das hat im Endeffekt nicht geklappt mit Havertz auf der Bank, aber ja, man kann ihm jetzt nicht vorwerfen, dass er nicht zumindest irgendwie eine Idee hat oder was versucht hat. Da war einfach dann auch Real Madrid in diesem Champions League-Modus, Großmotor, alle ausgeruht am Wochenende mit dieser brutalen Erfahrung und dann auch ein paar schicke Törchen, wieder Kavachalov, Vinicius spielt beim 1-0. Das ist dann eben auch schwer zu verteidigen und dann zu Hause im Bernabéu ist auch real schwer zu schlagen.
Du hast es ja schon gesagt, real im Champions League-Modus. Jetzt müssen wir aber an der Stelle, glaube ich, dann doch noch mal ganz kurz über das Bayern-Manchester City-Spiel sprechen, Jogi. Ein 3 zu 0, das unterschiedlich bewertet wurde von den Protagonisten, bei dem auch definitiv die kleinen Fehler den Unterschied gemacht haben, aber sie waren eben da und das Ergebnis ist auch entsprechend deutlich. Wie wäre denn dein Fazit zu dieser Auswärtsniederlage der Bayern?
Ja, dass die City-Maschine wieder rollt. Also das ist, glaube ich, das, was wir jetzt gelernt haben. Bayern München natürlich schon gut, aber ich habe das vor dem Spiel schon gesagt, dass ich glaube, dass diese defensiven Aussätze, die die Bayern immer mal wieder hatten, also so ein Gegentor war ja immer dabei, selbst wenn sie gewonnen haben, war es dann immer ein 3-1 oder ein 2-1. Das wird sich rächen, weil Manchester City momentan eben wieder richtig gut drauf ist. Das war mir fast klar, ich habe am Wochenende das Spiel kommentiert für Sky, es war mir fast klar, dass die im Moment jetzt wieder rollen werden. Weil Haaland ist wieder zurück, der ist richtig gut drauf, De Bruyne war wieder richtig gut drauf, Bernhard Silva war wieder gut drauf. Du hast es gemerkt, dass die einfach langsam aber sicher wieder kommen und dass die wieder marschieren und dass die jetzt auch wissen, es geht jetzt um alles, weil für die ist es halt genauso. Die können auch alles gewinnen und müssen es auch und müssen jetzt bei 100 Prozent sein ab April, weil sonst wird es mit Arsenal einholen nichts mehr und sonst wird es mit Bayern knacken nichts mehr und das haben sie gewusst und ich glaube in dem Modus waren sie. Und ja, wenn die Bayern sich dann so anstellen und der Upramikaner natürlich auch keinen guten Tag hatte, dann passiert das.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es gilt doch für die Bayern genauso, dass sie jetzt alles gewinnen müssen, also Pokal.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber ich meine, das ist halt schon das Interessante dadurch, dass die deutschen Medien logischerweise einen Fokus immer auf dem FC Bayern haben. Da habe ich das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, Jogi, wie es dir geht, du bist ja quasi so tief drin im Premier League Fußball, aber ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind auch einfach, also wir jetzt quasi so als die Berichtenden über Fußball, wir sind auch sehr gut darin, dann immer nur auf die Deutschen zu gucken und uns dann abzuleiten, ausnehmen, weiß nicht, 1 zu 0 gegen Freiburg am Wochenende. Mensch, die müssten doch jetzt eigentlich gegen City eine Chance haben und dabei hat man vielleicht gar nicht so einen Blick gehabt, dass City vielleicht gerade das heißeste Fußballteam Europas ist oder zumindest eines der heißesten und da muss man nicht nur über Erling Haaland reden, sondern da kannst du über so, also was Silva mit Davies gemacht hat, das war einfach grandios und City ist eben einfach eine verdammt gute Mannschaft und dann passiert so ein 0 zu 3 auch.
Ja, also ich war schon aber davor 50-50 ehrlich gesagt, weil für jedes Plus, das ich City gegeben habe, habe ich auch einen Plus bei Bayern gefunden, weil du halt immer bei Bayern, muss man schon sagen, Schlemmkriegs-Siegmodus, das ist bei Bayern München halt schon auch so und du weißt halt, dass die, wie sie gegen Paris gespielt haben, wenn sie sich zusammenreißen, wenn sie sich zusammenreißen wollen, können die ja defensiv stabil stehen und das war halt schon nur die Frage, ob sie das nicht irgendwie hinkriegen. Also ich hätte es den Bayern auch zugetraut, dass sie so ein 1-0 irgendwie durchwürgen.
Okay, na gut, dann war das vielleicht meine Sicht. Und dann haben wir noch die Italiener, Christian. Mit denen haben wir uns schon häufiger auseinander gesetzt, aber da gab es jetzt zwei Spiele, es sind ja noch drei italienische Mannschaften mit dabei. Einmal ein 2-0 von Inter bei Benfica auswärts und dann das Hinspiel zwischen Milan und Napoli im San Siro. Auch da gab es einen Platzverweis, auch da gab es viele kleine Geschichten. Was ist denn aus italienischer Sicht auf diesen Champions-League-Abend zu sagen? Ja, fangen wir mal mit dem Aktuellen an. Gestern Abend, Milan und Napoli. Napoli extrem gut gestartet. Ich glaube, 40 Sekunden war diese riesen Chorazkeliaschanz, wo sie eigentlich schon das 1-0 machen müssen. Danach auch weiter Druck gemacht, aber halt die Bude nicht gemacht. Und Milan muss man jetzt schon sagen, es ist jetzt schon das vierte Spiel in Serie, dass Piolli gegen Napoli im direkten Duell echt Lösungen findet. Vor kurzem gab es dieses 4-0 in der Liga in Neapel – überraschend. Da kann man vielleicht hinten anhängen, dass Napoli vielleicht unbewusst diese zwei, drei Prozent vielleicht weniger dabei war, weil die Meisterschaft so gut wie entschieden ist und sie wussten, jetzt kommen diese entscheidenden Spiele. Aber in der Hinrunde hat Napoli zwar in San Siro gegen Milan 2-1 ganz knapp spät gewonnen, aber da war Milan eigentlich auch leistungsmäßig besser. Und letztes Jahr in Neapel hatten sie auch schon gewonnen auf dem Weg zum Scudetto. Also Piolli hat da gegen Spalletti schon ein paar Knöpfe gefunden und dann machen sie eben dieses Umschalttor. Benasséa, guter Konter. Léo hatte auch einen unfassbaren Konter. Also Léo ist auch wieder da, wo Milan ihn braucht. Und was halt auch mit entscheidend war, bei Milan steht halt Menyar hinten drin und Menyar ist im Moment einer der stärksten Keeper Europas, gar keine Frage. Und das sind dann halt so ein paar Bausteine, wo dann am Ende, vor zwei, drei Wochen hätte glaube ich jeder gesagt, gut, Napoli in der Form, da gibt es für Milan nicht viel zu holen. So, und jetzt steht Milan aber da und geht mit einer guten Ausgangslage, wobei da ist schon alles noch drin. Also man darf auch nicht vergessen, bei Napolis hätte nicht nur Ossimen gefehlt, sondern auch Simeone verletzt und Raspadoi war auch noch auf der Bank. Er hatte keinen wirklichen Mittelstürmer. Schon wieder kein richtiger Neuner. Das zieht ja dieses Viertelfinale. Genau. Chelsea Bayern und Napoli. Stimp hat mit Elmas als falscher Neuner gespielt und trotzdem muss man jetzt sagen, Napoli hat viel herausgespielt. Also da ist logisch im Rückspiel alles noch drin. Ich bin mir sicher, dass Ossimen da spielen wird. Die haben ihn jetzt logisch da rausgelassen, damit er noch mal die Woche mehr hat. Was aber bitter aus Napolis Sicht ist, du hast es angesprochen, an Gisard, gelb-rot fehlt und Kim war gelb vorbelastet, hat sich wegen Meckern gelb geholt. Also Napoli hat sich auch so ein bisschen emotional mitreißen lassen und der Kim-Ausfall ist auch extrem schwerwiegend. Also ganz klar der Abwehrchef da hinten drin und vor allen Dingen einer auch, der Tempo hat und das ist glaube ich im Rückspiel gegen Leão, wenn Milan dann ja auch wieder ein bisschen umschalten kann, jetzt auch nach dem 1-0. Also der Kim-Ausfall ist glaube ich, würde ich sagen, mindestens gleich schwerwiegend wie der von An Gisard. Welche Rolle spielt es, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, dann kann Napoli jetzt, könnte Meister werden, jetzt am Wochenende. Spielt das für dich dann auch eine Rolle mit Blick aufs Rückspiel? Jetzt schon, das habe ich, also ich glaube, es ist noch zu früh, aber es ist demnächst dann auf jeden Fall möglich. Schauen wir uns nochmal zur Sicherheit. Also ich sage mal so, das glaube ich nicht, dass das jetzt so oder so den großen, den großen Ding hätte, was sie könnten, auf… 16 vor sind sie. 19 und dann wären es noch 8 Spiele. Hab ich mir einfach falsch gemerkt, entschuldigt bitte eine, die Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen schon, hatte ich neulich schon im Kurzpass, vielleicht so eine Kurzpasskrankheit. Im Kopf geht es nicht auf die anderen. Ne, wie gesagt, also ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht, ich finde auch, weil Napoli war ja auch nach den letzten zwei Ligen gespielt, hat man so die Frage gestellt, oh ist Napoli, haben sie so ein bisschen was vom Flow verloren? Und ich finde gestern gerade die Anfangsphase, hey, die waren da wie, also wie gar nichts. Also das war schon, deswegen würde ich das jetzt alles gar nicht groß damit reinnehmen. Das werden noch 90 Minuten in Maradona, vielleicht auch ein bisschen was Längeres. Also das wird schon noch eine große Aufgabe für Milan, weil Napoli schon auch ohne Osemen da gestern gezeigt hat, dass die schon noch, schon noch gut in der Spur sind. Ja, so und dann haben wir noch Inter bei Benfica, dem Team von Roger Schmidt. Da gab es ein 2 zu 0. Niccolò Barella macht das 1 zu 0 in der 51. Und dann Romelu Dukaku per Strafstoß. Klingelt irgendwas in der 82. Ja, was wurde Simone Insagi in den letzten Wochen an die Wand gestellt, kritisiert. Und dann reißt Inter da wirklich so ein reifes, so ein erfahrenes Spiel ab. Benfica, ja, eine der krassesten Offensiven in dieser Saison, in ganz Europa. Und, aber was Inter, also wie sie es auch angegangen sind, fand ich wirklich extrem reif. Also haben es dabei auch mit Ballbesitz ein bisschen probiert, nicht nur sozusagen tiefstehend. Haben immer wieder auch, sind situativ dann rausgestochen, haben Benfica unter Druck gesetzt und machen dann halt auch in der zweiten Hälfte, also das Tor, Pastoni, überragender Ball, der sich da vorne mit eingeschalten hat, auf dem zweiten Pfosten. Es gab danach noch gleich noch mal eine Kopie Pastoni Richtung Dumpfries, da können sie eigentlich auch schon das 2-0 machen. Also da haben sie sich auch gut gelesen, haben gut die letzte Kette attackiert, eben mit mehreren Spielern. Auch Barela ist eben immer aus dem Mittelfeld vorne mit rein. Also ich fand, das war schon, nach den Geschichten, die Inter ja zuletzt eben hatte, dass sie so lang silos waren in der Liga und in der Liga, wie gesagt, sind sie jetzt wirklich auch in Fünf zurückgerutscht. Aber eben was sie in der Champions League in dieser Saison zeigen, aus einer Gruppe mit Barca und Bayern rauszukommen, ist schon mal, finde ich, eine knifflige Aufgabe. Und jetzt dann auch wirklich eine sehr gute Ausgangsposition haben fürs Rückspiel Richtung Halbfinale. Also muss echt sagen, das war eine klasse Vorstellung von Inter. Und ein Wort noch zu Lukaku. Da gab es ein bisschen Aufregung beim Spiel gegen Juve unter der Woche. Ja, also das war das Coppa, Halbfinal-Hinspiel, sehr intensive Partie, richtig gutes Spiel. Er war von Anfang an Zug drin. Inter hat es auch da gut gemacht, hat die Tore nicht gemacht. Dann macht Juve spätestens 1-0. Da dachte man, ah, okay, wieder mal Inter, krieg's einfach nicht hin. Aber dann gleicht Lukaku in der Nachspielzeit bei Elfmeter aus. Ich glaube, das war sogar die 95. Also, war sehr emotional, war sehr hitzig. Lukaku ist dann mit Gelb-Rot geflogen, weil der Schiedsrichter seinen Torjubel als provokativ interpretiert hat, weil er sich so ein bisschen vor der Juvekurve hingestellt hat, salutiert. Aber das hat er auch bei der Bayerischen Nationalmannschaft schon gemacht. Das hat er jetzt auch beim Porto, bei Benfica-Spiel gemacht. Aber die Szene, die hässliche Geschichte war logisch, dass Lukaku in diesen letzten Minuten von den Rängen rassistisch beleidigt worden ist. Und ja, leider wieder mal so ein Vorfall. Ich sage mal so, was mir ein bisschen Hoffnung macht, wir hatten ja auch vor Kurzem bei Lazio gab es auch wieder solche Vorfälle, da hat Lazio drei Personen dann identifiziert, hat denen auch von sich aus lebenslanges Stadionverbot mit einem belegt. Und bei Juve, die haben jetzt anscheinend auch diese Personen, die da Richtung Lukaku diese Schmergesänge oder diese rassistischen Beleidigungen eben hatten, auch ausfindig gemacht. Also ich hoffe, dass auch wirklich, weil ich glaube, das kann die Liga allein nicht lösen. Da müssen auch die Vereine sozusagen energisch mit reingehen. Und ich hoffe, dass der Juve jetzt auch ein starkes Zeichen setzt und dass dann vielleicht das so ein erster kleiner Schritt ist, dass da einfach dem Ganzen entgegengewirkt wird. Denn ja, die Szenen gibt's leider immer wieder. Und schlimm, dass wir jetzt im Jahr 2023 immer noch über solche Geschichten reden müssen. Ja gut, aber wichtig, dass wir drüber reden, dass der Rassismus nicht weg ist. Es ist leider logisch, wenn man sich anguckt, wie unsere Gesellschaften funktionieren. Deswegen müssen wir es thematisieren. Ich muss aber einmal nochmal kurz nachhacken. Wenn ich richtig informiert bin, ist es ja so, dass der Block, aus dem diese Beleidigung kam, die auch das Schiedsrichterteam gehört hat und das Spiel dennoch nicht unterbrochen hat und dennoch auch entschieden hat, da Gelb-Rot zu zeigen, finde ich, kann man auch Anschlussfragen stellen. Aber der soll frei bleiben. Juwe möchte dagegen aber vorgehen, genauso wie die Sperre für Lukaku auch bestätigt wurde. Also die wurde die zweite gelbe Karte jetzt nicht aufgehoben. Ist das dann nicht wieder gleich, also wenn wir sagen, ja, auf der einen Seite ein gutes Zeichen, dass quasi die Menschen, die identifiziert wurden, dann mit Stadionverbot belegt werden, wird es dann nicht wieder aufgehoben, wenn man dann sagt, wir wollen aber jetzt gegen diese Block-Sperre vorgehen? Ja, kann man auf jeden Fall darüber diskutieren. Juwe hat so argumentiert, dass sie eigentlich die Verursacher persönlich bestrafen wollen, aber halt nicht den ganzen Block sozusagen. Das spielt sicher auch mit, dass nächste Heimstufe das Betroffene ist gegen Napoli. Das ist jetzt nicht das, sage ich mal, unwichtigste oder so. Und dementsprechend, ja klar, kann man da definitiv darüber diskutieren, dass Juwe nicht vielleicht auch sagt, hey komm, wir nehmen die Strafe jetzt an quasi. Wie gesagt, nochmal, die Juwe-Argumentation ist die, dass sie nicht sozusagen den ganzen Block in diese Haftung mit reinnehmen wollen. Wie gesagt, es ist eine kleine Hoffnung, ich weiß auch nicht, ob das reicht, aber vielleicht ist es ein erster kleiner Schritt, weil von Liga-Seite es kommen halt auch immer dieselben Geschichten. Ja, wir müssen was dagegen tun, dann wird wieder eine Kampagne gefahren, aber im Prinzip ist es halt oft nur Gerede. Und ich glaube, du musst die Clubs da auch mit reinnehmen. Und die Clubs müssen auch von sich heraus verstehen, dass sie da einfach mehr tun müssen, um dem Ganzen dann vielleicht auch irgendwie Schritt für Schritt Einhalt gebieten zu können. Ja, und die Konsequenz ist ja oft das Problem. Ich meine, wir hatten das mit den rassistischen Beleidungen auch jetzt gegen Dayo-Upper-Meccano, wo sich dann Bayern gleich positioniert. Und das ist alles – will ich nicht kleinreden – ist wichtig, dass das getan wird. Trotzdem kann man aber, wenn man sich die Aufarbeitung des Rassismus-Skandals am Nachwuchsleistungszentrum anguckt, dann auch die Frage stellen, seid ihr immer auch im Handeln so konsequent, wie ihr in den Symbolen seid, ohne dass sich da jetzt das abschließend beurteilen mag. Das kann man nicht mit 30 Sekunden einschuhen. Aber es ist wichtig, auch auf diese Ambivalenzen hinzuweisen, dass eben auch Taten folgen. Jetzt gab es einen, der musste ganz lange schweigen, weil nämlich kein französisches Team dabei ist, der schon bezieht. Sorry, da habe ich vorher nicht so richtig drüber nachgedacht. Deswegen, wir haben ja noch andere Teams, wir haben uns jetzt auch ein bisschen verquatscht. Du möchtest unter anderem mit uns über junge Hüpfer sprechen, die in Monaco herumhüpfen. Geht es schon wieder um Alex Nübel oder was?
Ich mache noch kurz eine wunderschöne Brücke, aber ich mache noch kurz einen anderen Schlenker, weil wenn wir schon von Europa sprechen, also tatsächlich der Stolz von Frankreich, das einzige Team, was in Europa übrig geblieben ist, ist Nizza. Die spielen heute Abend in der Conference League gegen Basel. Ansonsten ist da nichts übrig geblieben. Das erste europäische Viertelfinale für Nizza seit 63 Jahren. 1860 haben sie zuletzt gegen Real Madrid in der Coupe des Clubs Champion. Der Klassiker, wie wir es nennen. Genau. Nizza hat aber tatsächlich aktuell ein paar andere Problemchen. Die sind nämlich auch – da mache ich auch noch mal einen ganz kurzen Schlenker und eine Tür zu oder eine Tür auf und gleich wieder zu – seit gestern haben wir einen kleinen Skandal durch die französischen Sportblätter, weil Christophe Galtier, der aktuelle Trainer von PSG, da sollen E-Mails geleakt worden sein, während seiner Zeit in Nizza mit dem damaligen Sportdirektor, der jetzt auch nicht mehr da ist. Und da soll er sich dexpectierlich gegenüber Spielern geäußert haben, auch inklusive bis hin zu diskriminierenden oder rassistischen Aussagen. Das ist aber alles noch nicht wirklich bestätigt und deswegen würde ich diese Tür jetzt erstmal wieder schließen und das kann dann vielleicht in zwei Wochen bei der nächsten Ligatur dann, falls da was draus geworden ist, dann das aufgearbeitet werden, weil aktuell ist mir das noch ein bisschen zu sehr Gerücht. So genau. Und dann springen wir von Nizza ein paar Kilometer weiter nach Osten zu Monaco und in die Liga. Da hatte ich mir nämlich gedacht, wir können mal ein bisschen über Monaco sprechen, können gerne auch am Ende noch mal kurz über Nübel sprechen. Der passt da tatsächlich auch sogar noch mal kurz in die Story rein. Ich gebe euch noch mal kurz das große Bild. Also die Story ist ja, dass Monaco nach der Meisterschaft 17 ein ziemlich großes Loch gefallen ist. Die waren ja sogar noch fast im Abstieg entgangen und man hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass diese ganzen Mbappé-Millionen und Le Mans-Millionen und Fabinho-Millionen gar nicht so richtig genutzt wurden. Monaco ist ja traditionell durchaus ein Club, der auf Jugendausbildung werdet. Das war immer auch so ein bisschen der Fokus und das war jetzt auch wieder der Fokus, auf den man sich dann besonnen hat. Man hat mit Paul Mitchell einen Sportdirektor geholt, der ja auch zuletzt für den Red Bull Kosmos gearbeitet hat, aber auch anscheinend in Southampton und Tottenham ganz erfolgreich gewesen ist. Und dann jetzt mit Philipp Clément, einen Trainer, der auch in Brügge stark auf Jugend gesetzt hat. Und Mitchell hat sehr viel Geld bekommen, um da Training, Akademie zu modisieren, die Abteilung besser zu verzahnen. Und man konnte jetzt am vorvergangenen Wochenende, konnte man quasi symbolisch sehen, was da jetzt bei rausgekommen ist. Das war witzigerweise auch das Spiel, was ich noch sogar angekündigt hatte als C-Tip. Ligatour, Hörer wissen mehr. Das war das Spiel gegen Straßburg. Da gab es bei dem 4-2-Sieg von Monaco zwei Tore von zwei 18-Jährigen. Zur Pause hat Clément Elian Diop reingenommen. Das ist der Bruder von Sofiane Diop, der jetzt zu Nizza gewechselt ist. Der ist 18, der hatte schon ein paar Minuten gegen Leverkusen, gegen Tor gespielt, aber das war jetzt sein erstes Profitor gegen Straßburg. Das Zweite hat er direkt mit vorbereitet, hat sich da richtig spannend, beeindruckend eingebracht, schlaue Läufe, hat da die Abwehr von Straßburg gewirbelt, scheint einen guten Blick dafür zu haben, wie er im richtigen Moment so stehen kann, dass er aus dem Sichtfeld des Gegenspielers abtauchen kann. Atletisch hat er auch nach hinten mitgearbeitet, weil Monaco gegen das Spielende dann noch einmal weniger war. Also es war ein starker Auftritt und daneben war eben das große, große Super-Jungtalent, was jetzt schon in die Stammelf gespielt hat seit einiger Zeit, Elias Benzeguia. Ich weiß nicht, ob vielleicht, keine Ahnung, wie viele Ligatour-Hörer das Spiel von Monaco gegen Leverkusen geschaut haben in der Europa League. Da hat Benzeguia auch schon stark mitgearbeitet. Der ist eben auch 18, der ist durch alle möglichen U-Mannschaften gegangen, wo die Spieler dann zwei Jahre älter waren als er. Also war irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, U13-Meister, obwohl die anderen 15 waren. Und ist dann aber tatsächlich, und da schließt sich der Kreis zum Anfang, ist er tatsächlich zu Monaco gewechselt, weil er da das Gefühl hatte, dass er schneller als junger Spieler auch Einsatzzeiten bekommt. Sein Bruder ist nämlich zu Marseille gewechselt, der kommt da aktuell noch nicht zum Zug. Aber Elias Ivenseguir ist jetzt der Rising Shooting Star des Angriffs und das wird das nächste heiße Ding. Und das Kurios an der Sache ist, das sind noch nicht mal die einzigen Jugendspieler, die da aktuell Hoffnungen machen. Du hast in der Akademie auch noch so jemanden wie Magasa, das ist ein recht pressingresistenter Sechser. Du hast einen Kuli Bali, du hast einen starken Torwart und so weiter. Das sind jetzt wohlgemerkt alles Informationen. Also so viel Fußball, ich schaue jetzt nicht Monaco Jugend, muss ich zugeben.
Das macht nur Rufenschröder, denke ich.
Die habe ich aus dem sehr schönen Road to Nowhere Podcast, der so ein bisschen ähnliches Konzept hat wie die Ligatour. Die schauen auch in verschiedene Sachen rein. Und da war jemand zu Gast, der da über die Jugendakademie gesprochen hat und da dann nochmal alle möglichen Namen aufgezählt hat von Maybe the Next Fort Shit, der irgendwann kommt oder vielleicht auch nicht.
Also Benzegirr werden wir im Auge behalten. Ich sage jetzt einfach der nächste Mbappé. So macht man das doch, oder?
Genau, aber weil du es schon angedeutet hast und das Ergebnis drückt es ja auch so ein bisschen aus, 4 zu 2 gegen Straßburg.
4-3 sogar, oder?
4-3, stimmt, Entschuldigung, 4-3, genau. Die sind schon so ein bisschen fragil. So, die haben relativ viele Verletzungen in Abwehr gehabt, haben ziemlich viele Punkte nach Führung verloren. Klar haben natürlich auch Badia Schiel an Scherzi verloren im Winter. Und wir haben jetzt auch am Wochenende gegen Nords eine 2-0-Führung verspielt, noch mit 2 zu 2, unter anderem auch, weil der Torwart von Nords so stark war. Und da kommentierte die Equipe dann so ganz so fiesant, na ja, das wäre ja auch mal eine gute Strategie für Monaco, so ein Torwart. Also, Nübel nach wie vor eine Schwachstelle auf jeden Fall. Ist häufig nicht wirklich entschlossen auf der Linie, zögert, wenn er rausgehen soll, ist oft unkonzentriert. Oder war auch so ein Zitat, das ich gelesen habe in den vergangenen Wochen, ein ständiger Hoffnungsschimmer für den Gegner.
Wird denn in Frankreich auch immer die Frage bei jedem Gegentor diskutiert, hätte Neuer den gehalten?
Hätte Menyon den gehalten, ist wahrscheinlich dann die Frage.
Gut, David, danke dir. Jetzt wissen wir, wer der neue heiße Scheiß in der Ligue 1 ist. Das werden wir uns alle merken und werden sagen, in der Ligatur haben wir es zuerst gehört. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie ich von heißem Scheiß zu Premier League und zu Arsenal gegen Liverpool komme. Beide ja eigentlich. Wobei eigentlich nur eine Mannschaft. Gerade so der aktuelle heiße Scheiß. Aber das Spiel, Jogi, das du hier nochmal mitgebracht hast, über das wir nochmal kurz sprechen wollen, das hat es ja dann doch aus beiden Richtungen in sich. Denn am Ende war ja Arsenal, also man hat da das 2 zu 2 kassiert, relativ spät. Es gab noch einen verschossenen Strafstoß von Mo Salah. Also es hätte auch schon früher das Unentschieden fallen können. Im Nachhinein aber fast Arsenal ein bisschen glücklich davon gekommen zu sein mit einem Punkt. Würdest du es auch so sehen?
Also das Witzige ist, dass ich bin nach einer halben Stunde Marke nach Hause gefahren. Und als ich zu Hause angekommen bin, war dann die Schlussphase. Und es ging komplett ab und du hattest dann das Gefühl, oh mein Gott, es dreht sich. Und ich habe bis zum Schluss eigentlich gedacht, die verlieren das noch ehrlich gesagt. Weil ja, es ist mir unverständlich, ehrlich gesagt, das ist auch wieder das, was Christian vorher gesagt hat, so typisch Arsenal eigentlich. Das ist einfach nicht zu Ende spielen. Du gehst so dominant in diese Partie. Du machst aus zwei guten Szenentore, es geht sehr schnell alles. Du bist richtig dominant, du bist wieder richtig konzentriert. Du hast wieder typisch diesen tollen Arsenal-Fußball, den wir die ganze Saison über gesehen haben. Und dann, ja, mit dieser Granny-Chukka-Gelben-Karte ab der 40. Minute ging es los. Also in England ist geschrieben worden, du darfst alles machen, aber nicht den Fehler Anfield aufzuwecken. Und so war das Gefühl. Also dass dieser Streit in Anführungszeichen mit Liverpool, mit dem Schiedsrichter auch, dass das so die Anfield-Droids ein wenig aufgeweckt hat und dass es dann plötzlich losging. Eine Minute später das Gegentor kassiert, den Anschlusstreffer, dann, wie du gesagt hast, Elfmeter verschossen, er noch in der zweiten Hälfte. Und am Schluss war das ja dann einfach nur noch die Aaron-Ramsdale-Show. Wenn der nicht einen überragenden Tag gehabt hätte, dann hätte Arsenal dieses Spiel verloren.
Ja, da waren so einige Schüsse mit dabei. Da wäre ich mir nicht sicher gewesen, ob nur er den gehalten hätte.
Aber das ist eine Diskussion für andere.
Was würdest du denn jetzt sagen, wenn wir uns aufs größere Bild gucken? Sag das über Arsenal aus. Also man ist aktuell 6 Punkte vor, aber City hat noch ein Spiel weniger. Das heißt, wir können eigentlich, müssen bei der Form von City davon ausgehen, dass es 3 Punkte Unterschied sind und die beiden treffen sich noch. Und zwar in Manchester, wo wir jetzt ja gesehen haben, dass auch andere Teams Probleme hatten. Wie ist deine Prognose?
Also ich habe vor dem Spiel zu meinem Leiter der Sendung gesagt, ich hoffe, dass Arsenal gewinnt, weil dann bleibt die Meisterschaft spannend. Dann hat er mich so angeschaut, hä? Aber dann sind die doch weg. Ja, nein, ich glaube, dass die noch mal irgendwann wackeln werden. Und zwar nicht nur in dem City-Spiel. Deswegen glaube ich, wäre es gut für die Spannung, wenn sie das Spiel gewonnen hätten. Das Problem ist, ich habe das mal rausgeschrieben, weil ich City am Wochenende wieder habe, sie haben 16 der letzten 18 Spiele im April gewonnen. Das heißt, die sind dann da, wenn es wirklich wichtig wird. Und das ist halt die Frage, ob Arsenal das hat. Die hatten schon eine schwächere Phase und das dürfen sie sich jetzt nicht nochmal erlauben, weil City wird mit Sicherheit jetzt durchmarschieren. City hat das leicht, leichtere Restprogramm. Die spielen im Schnitt gegen den 10, 5. Arsenal und City gegen den 12. Deswegen, das ist alles so ein bisschen für City, noch nicht so 100%, aber so leicht. Dann treffen sie aufeinander, da wissen wir auch, was passieren kann. Ich muss echt sagen, das könnte wirklich knapp werden. Ich habe es auch mal durchgerechnet. Mit so einem Rechner, da wären sie wirklich punktgleich. Und City ist aufgrund des besseren Torverhältnisses das Meister geworden.
Dann ist Arling Haaland tatsächlich der, der sie zum Meister gemacht hat. Wir werden es sehen am 26. April, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das könnt ihr euch schon mal rot anstreichen. Da wird es dieses Spiel geben, wird dann natürlich auf Sky übertragen. Wer weiß, welche Hebel es da wieder involviert sein werden. Ich habe gehört, jetzt gibt es sogar Matchday of the Week. Match of the Week gibt es jetzt auch schon mit euch beiden. Aber das liegt in der Zukunft. Wir schauen auf die Gegenwart. Wir schauen nochmal nach La Liga. Nils, da müssen wir uns mit dem Abstiegskampf auseinandersetzen. Wir haben schon – du seufst schon – Wir haben es ja im Grunde schon… Ich kann doch nichts für dich. Oh je, Abstieg. Wir haben es ja letztlich schon vorbereitet. Ich habe das Gefühl, die ganze Ligatur der letzten drei Ausgaben war eigentlich so eine ständige Vorbereitung darauf. Stellt euch mal drauf ein, es könnte sein, dass Valencia absteigt. Was ist das neueste Update aus dem Zof?
Stellt euch mal darauf ein, dass der FC Valencia tatsächlich zum ersten Mal seit 1987 den Gang in die Segundadivision antreten könnte. Es gab hier und da nochmal Hoffnung, ein bisschen die Hoffnungsschlamme. Da hinten so leicht zieht man sie vielleicht noch durch den Trainerwechsel. Ruben Barracher ist ja so eine Spielerlegende, hat dort die Meisterschaft gewonnen, aber irgendwie dieses Argument erkennt den Club und ist eine Legende. Die schauen zu ihm auf, zählt auch nicht mehr. Er hat jetzt von seinen 7 Spielen 4 verloren, 2 Heimsiege knapp immerhin geholt, aber zuletzt eben auch am Wochenende. Ein direktes Abstiegsduell gegen Almeria verloren auch noch und das irgendwo verdient, wenn noch mit ein bisschen Pech. Die entscheidenden Spiele verliert Valencia einfach und deswegen sind sie jetzt in die Abstiegszone wieder reingerutscht, Platz 18 und es sieht einfach nicht gut aus in der Rückrunde. Da hat kein Team weniger Punkte geholt in La Liga. Die Mannschaft spielt sich schon hier und da ein paar Chancen und lässt auch gar nicht so viel zu, aber irgendwie es ist ein krasses Underperforming, was man dort so sieht, dass irgendwie wenig klappt, dass dort dann auch natürlich viel die Nerven blank liegen. So Paulista hatte da mal in Bernabeu sich so eine rote Karte geholt mit so einem Tritt gegen Vinicius, dass da einfach sehr viel im Argen liegt, dass dort einfach auch eine junge Mannschaft ist, die dann in den entscheidenden Momenten dann doch irgendwie im Strafraum versagt, weil Valencia hat einfach die jüngste Mannschaft der Liga und deswegen gibt es dort immer noch sehr viele Probleme. Also es sieht da nicht gut aus und zu Saisonbeginn hätte man schon getippt, so dass es für die jetzt nicht unbedingt Richtung Europa geht, aber dass sie wirklich absteigen und jetzt ist es einfach nur noch 10 Spieltage. Puh, ja, damit muss man sich langsam abfinden.
Jüngste Mannschaft der Liga und auch wegen dieser Unerfahrenheit gerät man da unten so richtig rein. Ich dachte, es wäre ein Missing in Tat, es ist zu Ajax gewechselt. Sorry, ich bin heute für die schlechten Bundesligare verraten. Shots fired. Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendjemand, ob das ein VfB-Fan gehört hat. Ich weiß es nicht. Gibt es darüber hinaus noch was zu sagen zu diesem Abstiegskampf in la Liga? Ich meine, auf dem Papier, es sind 2 Punkte aufs rettende Ufer. Du hast natürlich diese Almeria-Niederlage angesprochen. Das ist halt bitter, denn die sind damit jetzt 3 Punkte weg. Da sehen wir, wie wichtig eben dieses Spiel war. Aber es sind noch 10 Spiele, es sind nur 2 Punkte. Wenn ich mir die Konkurrenz angucke, Valladolid hängt da unten drin, Espanol, gut, die sind schon weg, die können wir absprechen. Aber Retafel, Cádiz, es könnte ja schon noch was passieren.
Ja klar, klar, es ist eng und Valencia hat jetzt auch viel, noch ein paar direkte Duelle gegen andere Abstiegskandidaten, so El Charles übernächstes, auch Valladolid, Cádiz, Villarreal. Das sind an sich alles irgendwo machbare Aufgaben, aber Valladolid für viele zeigt die Formkurve nach unten. Auch wenn jetzt ab und zu mal jeder holt mal so ein Sieg und irgendwie Sevilla hängt auch noch mit drin. Auch gegen die gibt es jetzt bald das Duell zwischen Sevilla und Valencia. Aber der Verein ist einfach irgendwie auch kaputt gewirtschaftet. Da muss ich auch natürlich einen besonderen Namen nennen. Das ist Peter Lim, der einfach für die letzten Jahre oder seit diesem Pokalsieg 2019 für einen riesigen Ausverkauf steht. Alles, was irgendwie Qualität hatte, wurde verkauft. Ob das irgendwie verdammt tolles war oder auch zuletzt im Sommer jetzt Carlos Soler, Guedes, Kangin Liden zu Mallorca. Deswegen hat man dort einfach auch wenig Erfahrung auf dem Platz. Und dann wird eher vielleicht nach Namen eingekauft, also dass so ein Justin Kloyward kam, Ilaik Smoriba, Ex-Basa, Talente, Edinson Cavani auch noch nicht so eingeschlagen. Auch auf der Trainerbank gab es da schon hier und da ein paar berühmte große Namen, ob das der Neville-Bruder hier war oder auch Gattuso jetzt zu Beginn der Saison, die einfach nicht so funktioniert waren. Dann hatte Lim keinen Bock, der Investor eben im Winter nachzurüsten. Und auch deswegen sind andere Vereine, die im Winter nachgerüstet haben, wie Cardis da ein bisschen wieder so ein Stück rausgeklettert, auch Almeria, auch wenn das eng ist. Aber das sieht einfach nicht gut aus. Aber klar, wie du schon gesagt hast, sind nur zwei Punkte aufs rettende Ufer. Es kommen noch entscheidende Duellen gegen andere Abstiegskandidaten. Valencia hat es in der eigenen Hand. Der Große, das, was noch Hoffnung macht, ist das Mestalla, wo man eben schon zwei Heimsiege unter Baracha geholt hat. Aber ob man sich daran wirklich festhangeln kann, um da dann den Klassenerhalt zu sichern, sei mal dahingestellt.
Das ist wirklich eine sehr schöne Zusammenfassung. Dann wollen wir uns mit Themen beschäftigen, die mehr Hoffnung machen. Und völlig logischerweise wollen wir damit sprechen über den Tabellen 8. oder den Tabellen 9. Mit wem von beiden bist du starten, Christian? Ja, fangen wir mal mit Bologna an. Also dem 8. Genau. Es klingt jetzt erstmal nicht so spektakulär. Platz 8. Aber sie sind an den europäischen Plätzen dran. Sie schnuppern dran. Und muss man vielleicht mal als Klammer setzen, für Bologna eine extrem emotionale Saison. Denn sie sind mit Sinisa Mihailovic als Trainer noch in die Saison gestartet. Und Mihailovic ist ja dann Ende letzten Jahres verstorben. Also ja, wie gesagt, klar, die ganze Mannschaft da auch extrem emotional eingebunden in diese Geschichte. Und ersetzt wurde Mihailovic aber im September schon von Thiago Motta. Ich glaube, der sagt dem einen oder anderen noch was. Große Spielerkarriere, Barca, Inter, PSG. Und Thiago Motta, da kommen wir jetzt gleich noch in Ruhe drauf zu sprechen, der bringt viel mit für eine große Trainerkarriere. Hat eben Bologna am 6. Spieltag übernommen, also schon relativ früh. Und seitdem haben in der Liga nur Napoli und Juve mehr Punkte als Bologna geholt. Oh, die Thiago-Motta-Tabelle. Ja, genau, die Thiago-Motta-Tabelle. Wenn man sich die dahin hängt, kann man aus Bologna-Sicht her, würde ich mal sagen, einen Haken dahinter machen. Also, es ist wirklich eine extrem starke Entwicklung, die die da genommen haben. Zuletzt auch jetzt am Wochenende haben sie Atalanta geschlagen, auswärts. Atalanta ist ja auch noch mitten im Rennen um die Champions-League-Plätze. Also, da musste man auch erstmal gewinnen. Sie haben Inter vor kurzem geschlagen, haben gegen Lazio gepunktet. Also, Bologna ist wirklich seit Monaten jetzt eigentlich schon in einem Modus, wo du sagst, okay, das kann sich ansehen lassen. Und das hat eben sehr viel mit der Personalität Thiago Motta zu tun. Als Spieler erinnere ich mich wahrscheinlich noch ein paar ganz wichtige Mann im Mittelfeld. Einer, der jetzt nicht für die großen Highlight-Szene vielleicht immer da war, aber extrem wichtig für die Balance einer Mannschaft. Teil des Triple Inters von 2010 unter Mourinho. Ganz wichtiger Faktor auch in der italienischen Nationalmannschaft. Einer, den man damals schon hatte ansehen können, das könnte Trainer werden. Und genau das zeigt er jetzt. Ist 2019, also jetzt vor ein paar Jahren, hat er dann seine Profi-Trainer-Karriere gestartet. Genoa, wo er auch schon Spieler war, hat ihm die Chance gegeben. Davor hat er nur die Paris PSG U19 trainiert. Der damalige Genoa-Präsident Preziosi hat gesagt, er ist ein Riesentalent, ich will, dass er jetzt bei uns anfängt. Das war eine relativ schwierige Konstellation da, die war nicht so erfolgreich. Aber Preziosi hat damals schon gesagt, hört mir gut zu, das wird einer der besten Trainer Europas in den nächsten Jahren. Also der hat schon was in ihm gesehen. Und jetzt ist es so, er ist dann weiter zu Spezia, die hat in der Liga gehalten, letzte Saison, da war nicht mehr drin, da ging es einfach um den Klassenhalt. Und jetzt bei Bologna siehst du viele von Ideen. Er spielt einen sehr variablen Fußball, viele Positionswechsel. Da kann man oft im Spiel gar nicht, spielt er Viererkette, spielt er Dreierkette, das kannst du oft gar nicht so richtig rauslesen, weil die so viel in Bewegung sind. Echt geben dem Gegner wenig Anhaltspunkte. Ist echt sehr gut anzusehen und du siehst jetzt, er hat jetzt ein Spielermaterial bei Bologna, das einfach qualitativ hochwertiger als bei Spezia ist. Und was er jetzt mit denen eben schon macht, das ist sehr, sehr ansehnlich. Aber wenn du sagst, es ist so fluide, dass es gar nicht so zu greifen ist für den Gegner, was ist denn dann so die Philosophie? Will man den Ball haben? Will man Chaos stiften? Wie will man Kontrolle über den Ball bekommen? Also im Zentrum steht ganz klar das Besetzen der Räume. Also das, was ja auch viele Trainer jetzt logisch im Fokus haben. Andrea Cambia, so einer der jungen Bologna-Spieler, hat zuletzt auch in einem Interview gemeint, Thiago Mata ist, was das betrifft, seiner Zeit voraus. Also er hat gesagt, er ist ganz weit weg von diesem alten Positionsdenken. Also Linksverteidiger ist Linksverteidiger, Rechtsverteidiger bleibt nur da, sondern da ist wahnsinnig viel. Es geht einfach ums Besetzen der Räume. Und deswegen meinte ich, ist es eben auch sehr beweglich. Ja, es geht schon in die Richtung, weil es ist echt interessant, da jetzt vielleicht auch schon der erste kleine Hinweis, am Wochenende spielt Bologna gegen Milan. Also das kann man sich echt mal anschauen, weil ich habe Bologna diese Saison ein paar Mal gemacht und du hast immer gemerkt, dass der Gegner, eben auch gerade die Großen, die mussten sich immer erst ein bisschen darauf einstellen. Weil eben wie gesagt, mal greifen sie mit einer, oder bauen sie erst eine Viererkette heraus auf, wo du glaubst, okay, jetzt kommt ganz normal, die Außenverteidiger kommen ganz normal, dann gehen aber die Außenverteidiger ganz oft in die Haltpositionen, zentral rein, viele Positionsverschaden eben. Das sind offensiv Außenspieler, die dann oft dem Außenverteidiger den Rücken frei halten, damit der eben vorne mit rein gehen kann. Also es sind echt schwer zu greifen. Und da sieht man eben so die Idee von Thiago Motta, die er schon am Anfang seiner Trainer-Karriere hatte, wo sie vielleicht noch nicht so ganz gegriffen hat, weil auch das Material nicht da war. Aber wenn du dem eben, glaube ich, Spielermaterial in die Hand gibst, die diese Ideen aufsaugen, dann kommt da viele bei rum. Und man darf eben auch nicht vergessen, er ist einer, als Spielerin war er bei Jena, war er lang unter Gasparini-Spieler, also ist er auch einer, darüber haben wir auch schon mal gesprochen, der so ein bisschen aus dieser Gasparini-Schule rauskommt, hat auch jetzt vor dem direkten Duell am Wochenende gemeint, hat wahnsinnig viel von ihm gelernt. Aber man darf halt auch nicht vergessen, er hat als Spieler unter Trainern wie Guardiola, Ancelotti und Mourinho gespielt. Also der hat wirklich auch viel von den ganz Großen quasi mitgenommen und deswegen ist er wirklich ein extrem, extrem spannender Mix. Gasparin hat jetzt am Wochenende gesagt, es gibt wenige, die so viel wissen, wie der Fußball läuft, wie Thiago Motta. Also auch er traut ihm eine richtig große Trainerkarriere zu. Er ist wirklich ein spannender Personale. Und wenn man die Gerüchte ein bisschen verfolgt, bei PSG fiel sein Name jetzt schon mal. Auch logisch doch seine Vergangenheit da. Bei Inter fiel der Name auch jetzt, weil ja die Frage ist, was da im Sommer passiert mit Simone Nsagi. Also er hat sich jetzt auch schon in dieser Phase wirklich für Höheres beworben. Und ich glaube auch, dass wir den nicht mehr sehr, sehr lange auf der Trainerbank von Bologna sehen werden. Wahnsinn. Wir brauchen einen Begriff für die Trainer, die von Gasparini geprägt wurden. Die Gasparininios. Die Kinder des Gasparini. Das stimmt. Ein letzter Satz noch dazu, weil es vielleicht auch ein bisschen Bezug eben Richtung Deutschland ist. Stefan Posch spielt in Bologna, Ex-Hoffenheim. Ja, stimmt. Und der ist wirklich so ein bisschen ein Sinnbild für diese wenig Anhaltspunktegebenden. Der ist ja eigentlich Innenverteidiger, spielt aber jetzt viel als Rechtsverteidiger, spielt aber auch in der Dreierkette. Das kennt er alles von Alfons Schreude. Und Achtung, jetzt festhalten, der hat in der Saison schon fünfmal geknipst. Ist in der Liga drittbester Torschütze von Bologna. Also ist wirklich so einer dieser Spieler, der unter Thiago Motta wirklich eine extreme gute Entwicklung genommen hat. Und ja, ich sag mal, fünf Tore als Außenverteidiger, Schrägstrich Innenverteidiger, können sich sehen lassen, würde ich mal sagen. Und eben, wie gesagt, eben auch einer von denen, der, wenn du dir die Heatmaps von Bologna-Spieler anschaust, die ist sehr, sehr breit aufgestellt auf dem Feld. Also da, wie gesagt, da geht es drunter und drüber, aber in einem positiven Sinn. Also das Chaos sozusagen, wenn wir es mal so nennen wollen, hat System und das funktioniert sehr gut. Ach Mensch, Thiago Motta Bologna, das muss man sich wirklich angucken. Ihr habt schon mitbekommen, das war schon das erste Match to Watch, dann am Wochenende. Lasst noch mal in die Ligue 1 springen. David, du möchtest mit uns über zwei eher unerwartete Pokalfinalisten sprechen. Was ist schon wieder los bei PSG?
PSG ist schon lange raus aus dem Pokal. Genau. Ihr hattet ja schon mal in der Ligatour vor, keine Ahnung, ein oder zwei Jahren über den französischen Pokal gesprochen. Ich meine, dass da Alexi damals da war, der auch so ein bisschen ausgeführt hat, dass ja der französische Pokal dadurch geprägt ist, immer wieder auch kleiner klassierige Vereine mit reinzulassen, zwei Drittligisten, sogar mal Amateure. Wir hatten einen Drittligisten im Finale, sogar 2018. Wir hatten in den vergangenen 20 Jahren auch zweimal Amateur im Finale. Und auch jetzt hatten wir zumindest einen Zweitligisten im Halbfinale und haben jetzt im Finale zwei Vereine stehen, die zumindest nicht in den ersten zehn der Liga auftauchen. Wobei immerhin einer von den beiden der vorjährige Sieger ist, nämlich Nord. Also die sind da jetzt nicht zum ersten Mal, aber die kämpfen aktuell so mehr ein bisschen gegen den Abstieg. Und die Favoriten sind tatsächlich alle schon raus, aber den großartigsten Weg hat Masai hingelegt, weil die haben zuerst Rennen rausgeschmissen, dann haben sie PSG im Achtelfinale besiegt, und dann sind sie im Viertelfinale am Zweitligisten gescheitert.
War das an Annecy, oder?
Das war Annecy, genau. Und Lyon hatte Lil rausgeschlagen, die sind jetzt im Halbfinale dann an Nord gescheitert. Monaco hat sich auch plamiert, ist in der ersten Runde direkt auch gegen Zweitligisten raus. Also die großen Favoriten sind jetzt alle besiegt. Lyon war sozusagen der letzte noch große Verein, wobei da auch nochmal deutlich geworden ist, dass sie ein bisschen morsch sind und ein ganzer Menge an Problemen haben. Und jetzt haben wir ein so noch nicht gespieltes Finale. Nantes, fangen wir mal an, die kurz vorzustellen. Das ist gar nicht so eine kleine Stadt. Also mit ganzem Greater Area drum herum sind es 500.000 Leute im Westen. Das war historisch einige Zeit lang die Hauptstadt der Britannier. Immerhin auch schon französischer Meister achtmal, aber ebenso vor allem in den 60ern und 80ern. Und dann nochmal eine starke Phase Ende der 90er. Ich glaube daher kennen wir sie wahrscheinlich auch, wenn wir so ein bisschen auf Fußball schauen. Mit auch zwei Pokalsiegen. Und da hat Antoine Comboire 2021 übernommen nach diesem Desaster Raymond Domenech, der, glaube ich, als Name auch noch an der Glocke klingeln dürfte. Der war bei Nantes als Vereinstrainer genauso unerfolgreich wie er es als Nationaltrainer war für Frankreich. Comboire hat sich dann vor dem Abstieg gerettet und seitdem dann immerhin den Pokal geholt und sie ja auch in Europa League geführt. Sie haben ja gegen Freiburg auch gespielt. Und eigentlich wollte er da auch nicht jetzt unbedingt länger bleiben. Norn hat immer so ein bisschen das Problem von ein bisschen schwierigen Strukturen. Er hat immer wieder gesagt, dass da teils shady Berater ein bisschen zu viel Einfluss haben. Und der Chef, Valdemar Kieta, ist auch so ein durchaus zwielichtiger Geschäftsmann irgendwie. Aber Comboire ist jetzt erstmal geblieben. Und steht zum zweiten Mal im Finale. Ganz spannende Person, er selbst auch. Stammt aus Übersee-Department, Neu-Caledonien. Sein erster Klub war tatsächlich Norn. Da war er 20 Jahre alt, hat da 7 Jahre gespielt, ist dann zu PSG gewechselt. War da auch später Trainer, als die Kataris übernommen haben und ist dann nämlich dort entlassen worden. Weil ich glaube, Katar direkt mehr bling bling wollte als so einen französischen Trainer, der noch nicht wirklich viele Erfolge vorzuweisen hatte.
Und muss man der Fairness halber zu sagen, danach hatten die Kataris wirklich ein goldenes Händchen als Trainer.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Genau, ich glaube, das war sogar das Jahr, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, wo Combo Arré auf Platz 1 entlassen wurde und dann sitze zweiter geworden am Ende. Also, ja, genau. Und Spieler des Halbfinals für Nantes war Ludovic Blass. Der war lange Zeit so ein bisschen ein ewiges Talent. Ich bin so ein bisschen überrascht, dass der erst 25 Jahre alt ist. Der ist seit 18 Jahren schon in der Liga. War auch da U19-Europameister zusammen mit einem gewissen Mbappé. Und hatte seinen Profi-Stadt damals bei Gerngang. Hat da mit einem, ebenfalls uns nicht ganz unbekannten, Marcus Tiram zusammen gespielt. Und es hieß immer wieder, ja, der wird da seinen Durchbruch haben, wird seinen Durchbruch haben. Und da kam immer so lange Zeit nicht so der, der, der, der, der Staat, der ihn dann ins europäische Bewusstsein katapultiert hätte. Hatte in Norn vielleicht auch ein bisschen das Problem, dass er da wiederum das zusammen spielen sollte mit einem Colombo-Muerni. Und dann ja nicht so klar so, wo schiebt man Blas jetzt hin? Nach links, nach Mitte, nach rechts. Und er sollte eigentlich schon weg sein nach Lille im vergangenen Jahr. Dann hat er bei Combo Aresenveto eingelegt und hat ihn da behalten. Vermutlich aber mit dem Versprechen, dass er jetzt tatsächlich mal wechseln darf. Und hat sich tatsächlich in diesem Jahr nochmal richtig stark entwickelt. War eindeutig bester Spieler von Norn gerade. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wo der hingeht. Ob da vielleicht irgendein europäischer Verein sogar zuschnappen würde.
Und was ist zu Toulouse zu sagen? Die ja in der Tabelle, also Norn liegt auf Platz 14, Toulouse auf Platz 12.
Genau. Toulouse sind erst 2022 wieder aufgestiegen. Die haben sich es auch gar nicht unbedingt gleichgemacht gegen Annecy. Und Toulouse war als Stadt wohlgemerkt zuletzt 57 im Finale. Also wir haben heute die Aufnahme der 50er- 60er-Jahre-Referenz. Ist jetzt auch keine Fußballstadt so rücklich. Eigentlich ist eine Rugby-Stadt. Der Rugby-Verein dort ist Rekordmeister. Ich glaube, jetzt zu dem Halbfinale sind unter 1000 Fans mitgereist nach Annecy. Die mussten auch ans andere Ende des Landes, von Westen nach Osten reisen, in die Alpen. Schon ein weiter Weg. Und es gab einen Verein in Toulouse, einen Fußballverein, der war in den 50er-Jahren Pokalsieger und so. Der hat sich aber 67 aufgelöst. Er hat dann seinen Kader und seinen Liga-Platz an Red Star Paris verkauft. Der aktuelle Verein ist erst in den 80er-Jahren gegründet. Der beruft sich manchmal ein bisschen gerne auf die Tradition, aber letztlich ist es ein vergleichsweise neuer Verein. Der war dann seit den 2000ern fast durchgängig in der ersten Liga, hat auch ein paar Mal in Europa mitgemischt. Aber das ist jetzt schon so der große Erfolg, der Toulouse bevorstehen könnte. Bates hat da begonnen, Fabian Bates. Später hat auch Jean-Jacques da gespielt, als er zum Nationaldreher wurde. Und bis 2020 hat auch Combo Arré da trainiert.
Ach ja.
Interessanterweise. Genau. Also es wird auf jeden Fall irgendeine schöne Story geben. Entweder wird Nantes einen Doppelsieg einfahren oder Toulouse wird seinen ersten großen Titel gewinnen.
Na, und wann ist das Finale?
In drei Wochen, also es ist noch eine Ligatur davor, am 29. April.
Okay, dann werden wir danach da nochmal drauf gucken müssen, auf jeden Fall welche der schönen Geschichten es geworden ist. Wir haben noch zwei Themen, die wir noch absprechen wollen. Das überlege ich gerade. Nee, von der schönen Geschichte. Ich bau jetzt einfach keine direkte Brücke. Ich sag einfach Nies, du hast nur ein Thema mitgebracht. Eins, dass es vielleicht auch schon ins Bewusstsein von manchem Hörer und mancher Hörerin geschafft hat. Denn da ist was passiert in La Liga, was nicht mit Sportleben zu tun hat.
Da ist was passiert in La Liga, wo es bestimmt auch schon einige Artikel zu lesen gab, auch im deutschsprachigen Raum. Am Samstag das Spiel von Real Madrid gegen den FC Villarreal. Das Spiel hat Real Madrid verloren mit 2 zu 3. Aber das Große ist eher nach dem Spiel deutlich nach Abpfiff passiert. Also auch außerhalb des Stadions im Parkhaus auf dem Weg zum Bus. Da hat dann eben Federico Valverde noch den Spieler vom FC Villarreal, Alex Baena, eine verpasst ins Gesicht geschlagen. Da hat er so am linken Wangenknochen auch so einen leichten Blutfleck. Und das ist erstmal die große Geschichte. Warum? Was ist da passiert? Da soll es wohl zu einer – also ist noch nicht bestätigt oder kann nicht nachgewiesen werden, weil es kam wohl zu einer Aussage auf den Platz. Und das schon Wochen vorher, Mitte Januar, da hat Federico Valverde mit seiner Freundin Mina Bonino eine sehr harte Phase durchgemacht. Ihm wurde von einem Arzt bestätigt, dass sie eine Fehlgeburt kriegen werden. Mina Bonino ist schwanger, aber es hieß, das Kind wird es nicht schaffen. Und das kam da im Januar raus. Real Madrid war dann Mitte Januar, hat dann bei Villareal gespielt, im Pokal dort 3-2 gewonnen. Und dort soll dann angeblich dieser Alex Baena zu Federico Valverde gesagt haben, heul doch, dass dein Sohn nicht geboren wird. Also eine abgrundtief hässliche Aussage, die man tätigen kann, die nichts mehr mit Beleidigungen im Fußball zu tun hat, was auch nicht schön ist, im Fußball zu beleidigen. Aber das ist eben so eine krasse Aussage. Und es kam damals eben nicht zu einer Reaktion von Valverde. Es ist sogar noch gut ausgegangen, die Aktion. Denn ein paar Tage später hat Mina Bonino dann im Februar verraten über das soziale Netzwerk, dass es dem Kind doch irgendwie gut geht. Oder ich zitiere sie mal kurz, ihre Nachricht. Wir haben uns einen Monat lang auf das Schlimmste vorbereitet. Und nachdem ich einen ganzen Monat lang geweint und getrauert habe, während ich meinen zweiten Sohn einen Bauch hatte, erreichte uns gestern die am wenigsten erwartete Nachricht. Den Baby geht es gut. Das ist schon mal die wichtige Nachricht. Dem Baby geht es gut und es wird kommen. Aber da war es dann eben so, dass jetzt bei dem erneuten Aufeinandertreffen zwischen Real Madrid und Villarreal, Alex Boaena wohl erneut irgendwas Richtung Valverde gesagt haben soll. Und dann Valverde ihm klar gemacht hat, du, wir treffen uns noch nach dem Spiel. Und ja, da kam es dann eben im Parkhaus vor vielen Zeugen. Das war mehr oder weniger auch abgesprochen, abgemacht. Eben Boaena wusste, dass ihm da was erwarten könnte. Valverde hat ein paar Mitspieler mitgenommen. Die Polizei war dort oder zumindest ein paar Securitys, die das eh alles irgendwie abschweren, die diese Bus abfahrt. Ja, und dann gab es eben so einen Schlag von Valverde in Boaenas Gesicht. Das ist klar nachzuweisen, wurde auf der Kamera festgehalten. Nur eben, dass es zu dieser angeblichen Tataussage von Boaena gegen Boaede kam. Das ist halt das Schwierige. Das ist auch, das sind wir jetzt auch bei einer schwierigen Sache. Das ist Boaenas oder Alex Boaena hat mittlerweile auch eine kleine Mitteilung rausgebracht. Und er stützt sich aber auch auf die Tatsache, dass es keine Beweise gibt, dass er diese Aussage tätig hat. Also er sagt nicht, das stimmt nicht, dass ich das gesagt habe. Das ist eine Lüge, das ist erfunden. Er sagt nur, es gibt keine Beweise, dass ich das gesagt haben soll. Und das ist dann eben auch eine sehr schwierige Argumentation, wie sich eben, ja, was weiß ich, jeder weiß, dass die WM in Katar gekauft wurde, aber es gibt da keine Beweise. Und so ähnlich ist scheint das jetzt auch dazu fallen. Und da ist dann die Frage, wie weit kann man seine Ehre retten? Die Ehre der Familie, wie gerechtfertigt ist das natürlich nicht ein Schlag, dann den Gegenspieler zu schlagen. Gewalt ist keine Lösung, aber ja, der eine oder andere kann vielleicht doch verstehen, dass da Valverde außerhalb des Spielfelds, um nicht gleich eine rote Karte zu kriegen und seinen Verein zu benachteiligen, da einen Weg gesucht hat, um irgendwie so diese Ehre der Familie, das kann ich als deutsche Kartoffel auch nur schwer nachvollziehen, da wiederherzustellen. Das ist mal so als großer Aufreger in Spanien.
Ich muss sagen, Männer sind mir einfach zu emotional. Männerfußball ist nichts für mich. Wird das auch thematisiert? Ich meine, im Detail muss man da jetzt nicht drüber diskutieren, wie man sich da verhalten hätte. Aber dass dem Ganzen ein – und das Trash-Talk und so weiter dazu gehört. Aber wie – also welch schlechtes Licht es eigentlich auf beide wirft und letztlich auch auf die Konfliktlösungsmöglichkeiten und auch das Konfliktschüren, das man da macht. Wird sowas auch diskutiert? Oder geht es halt eher darum, wer hat jetzt was gesagt und so weiter?
Ja, es ist in Spanien einfach generell der große Aufreger, dass es da zu so einer Tätigkeit kam nach dem Spiel. Gar nicht groß, das Äthischen der Fragen, so diese Frage der Ehre. Ist das noch irgendwie vertretbar? Im Endeffekt, weil Werder wird jetzt seine Strafe bekommen über ein Gericht, weil bei ihnen hat das zur Anzeige gebracht. Und ob das dann eine Geldstrafe wird oder dann irgendwie noch ein besonderes Komitee ihn auch noch generell in Spanien für Spiele sperren kann, ist da nochmal offen. Aber ich denke mal, er hat das schon mit einkalkuliert, weil er hat eben für sich entschieden, ich werde das nicht hier auf dem Platz tun, diesen Schlag verpassen oder diese Ehre wieder herstellen, sondern eben nach dem Spiel, um einem Verein nicht zu schaden. Ich glaube, das war schon alles so kalkuliert. Aber die Aufregung ist halt generell mal wieder in der Liga, dass Dinge passieren, die man nicht nachweisen kann, wo dann eben Spieler sich rausreden. Es gab auch schon diverse Rassismus-Skandale, Kallar gegen die AKB, wo es auch zu angeblich einer rassistischen Aussage kommen sein soll. Aber konnte man Kallar nicht nachweisen, also darf der immer noch weiter Fußball spielen. Und vielleicht ist er ja auch unschuldig, kann ja sein, weil man es eben nicht nachweisen kann. Aber es gibt einfach so viele Fälle mittlerweile, dass es einfach da ein sehr nerviges Thema, dass sowas immer wieder passiert. Und natürlich sollen die Spieler auch nicht mit Mikrofon spielen und natürlich soll auch ein Federico Valverde sein Gegenspieler danach nicht schlagen. Wir reden über physische Gewalt, aber es kam halt davor auch schon zu psychischer Gewalt. Wenn die wochenlang denken, dass ihr Kind sterben wird, darf man darüber keine Witze machen. Also in keiner Welt darf man das. Kann man nicht schönreden, aber irgendwie eine Reaktion, weiß nicht, ob man das verstehen kann. Das muss jeder wahrscheinlich für sich selbst überlegen.
Und weil es eben so ein großer Aufreger war, war es sicherlich auch gut, das hier nochmal ein bisschen ausführlicher zu besprechen, als es auch in Medien gelandet ist. Ich habe unter anderem eine Schlagzeite gelesen. Wir haben noch ein Thema aus der Serie A. Wir wollen uns mit der Fiorentina beschäftigen, Christian. Und könnte es damit zusammenhängen, dass wir uns deswegen mit ihnen auseinandersetzen, weil sie unter anderem neunmal in Folge in Pflichtspielen gewonnen haben. Und insgesamt, wenn ich mich jetzt gerade nicht erzählt habe, aus den letzten 13 Spielen Pflichtspielen ungeschlagen sind und daraus 11 Siege und zwei Unentschieden geholt haben. Du bist und bleibst einfach ein Fuchs. Ja, die nächste heiße Mannschaft. Und weil du vorhin ja auch gemeint hast, wir schauen jetzt auf Platz 8 oder 9, ist ja auch schön, über die Großen haben wir ja immer wieder gesprochen. Aber es gibt eben auch ein paar Mannschaften, die auch ihre Sache in Italien sehr, sehr gut machen. Und dazu gehörten in Bologna selbstverständlich auch die Fiorentina. Du hast sie schon angesprochen, haben am Wochenende knapp ihren zehnten Sieg in Folge verpasst. 1-1 gegen Spezia, sind aber weiter ungeschlagen. Rollen das Feld so ein bisschen von hinten auf, denn eben vor dieser Siegeserie lief es ergebnistechnisch überhaupt nicht in der Liga, waren wirklich relativ weit zurück. Aber das Spannende war, dass das damals wirklich auch nur die Ergebnisse waren. Denn wenn man sich die Fiorentinaspiele angeschaut hat und nicht nur die Spiele, sondern auch die Statistiken dazu, die Fiorentina war schon zu der Zeit, als es nicht lief, ergebnismäßig, in ganz vielen Offensivstatistiken die Nummer 2 der Liga nur von Napoli geschlagen. Also was Torschüsse betrifft, was herausgespielte Chancen, was Ball besitzt, in all den Kategorien war auch da schon nur Napoli stärker. Also es zeigt, das 4-3-3 von Italiano ist Vincenzo Italiano, der Trainer, auf dem kommen wir auch noch, hat da eigentlich schon gegriffen, nur was gefehlt hat, katastrophale Chancenverwertung. Da hat ihnen vorne drin der Knipser gefehlt, Vlaović nochmal kurz, die Klammer wurde ja letzten Januar für sehr, sehr viel Geld an Juve abgegeben. Und das haben sie letztes Jahr an der Rückrunde noch auffangen können, aber bis Januar, Februar eben in dieser Saison nicht. Da haben Jović, der immer wieder verletzt war, nicht so geliefert, kommen wir auch gleich drauf. In den Pokalwettbewerben schon, in der Liga nicht. Cabral, den sie aus der Schweiz geholt haben, Brasilianer, hat auch nicht geknipst, aber gerade dieser Cabral hat jetzt angefangen zu knipsen und seitdem läuft es bei der Fiorentina, weil sie eben, wie gesagt, vom Ansatz her schon davor sehr, sehr gut unterwegs war, sehr mutig, sehr intensiv, 4-3-3, muss man den Kapitän Christiano Biragi nennen, Linksverteidiger, aber wenn du dir Fiorentina-Spiele anschaust, da sind die Außenverteidiger, gerade im Ballbesitz, haben die relativ wenig mit Außenverteidiger-Position zu tun, sondern ganz oft an der Grundlinie gehen, ganz vorne mit rein. Die Fiorentina bringt viele Spieler an den gegnerischen 16er, dementsprechend spielt sie sich eben vieles raus. Gutes Pressing, das war immer auch schon eine Stärke von Vincenzo Italiano. Also wirklich eine sehr, sehr gut anzusehende Mannschaft vor kurzem. Sie haben jetzt Milan und Inter in dieser Serie geschlagen vor kurzem. Das war dieses 1-0 in San Siro gegen Inter. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch ein paar daran, da lässt Lukaku eine Chance liegen, das glaubst du eigentlich nicht, dass irgendwie aus einem Meter leeres Tor und er setzten noch daneben. Aber das war so ein bisschen sinnbildlich, weil Fiorentina-Spieler wirklich, ja, da geht es hin und her, da ist viel Alarm drin, die Fiorentina macht viel fürs Spiel, ist mutig, also ist wirklich sehr ansehendlich. Und jetzt kommen wir eben zum Punkt, es geht ja nicht nur um diese Siege sehr in der Liga, sondern sie haben auch noch die Chance auf zwei Titel. Sie sind in der Conference League heute Abend gegen Lech Posen, das Hinspiel. Super im Rennen, haben da glaube ich die letzten Spiele alle gewonnen auch. Also haben auch ganz klar das Ziel, wir wollen da Richtung Finale. Und sie sind in der Coppa Italia, haben sie das Halbfinale-Hinspiel gegen Überraschungsmannschaft Cremonese auswärts 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Haben also wirklich sehr, sehr gute Karten da ins Finale einzuziehen. Da wird es dann gegen Into oder Juve gehen, also das wird ein richtig heißes Match auch werden. Also die Fiorentina ist eine Pokalmannschaft in dieser Saison, aber eben was die Leistung betrifft, auch in der Liga, jetzt belohnen sie sich für das, was sie eigentlich schon über die ganze Saison zeigen. Und interessante Transferstrategie, also du hast es ja schon angesprochen. Also wir kennen Luca Jovic, der ist jetzt gefallen. Arthur Cabral, der kam vom FC Basel damals. Und González vom VfB ist ja auch dorthin gewechselt. Absolut, das ist zum Beispiel – González war auch so ein Faktor, da war er in der Saison immer wieder verletzt, hat ja auch die WM verpasst. Der wäre eigentlich Teil des argentinischen Kaders gewesen, war jetzt ja auch wieder ein Perrufen bei der Argentinier. Der hat ihnen lange gefehlt, also der kommt jetzt auch wieder ins Rollen. Sofian Amrabat sagt wahrscheinlich einigen jetzt seit der WM was. Der so extrem wichtige Anker Marokkos vor der Abwehr quasi. Also da ist Qualität da und da ist aber auch ein Ansatz von Vincenzo Italiano eben, von diesem Trainer, der diese Qualitäten auch versucht, sehr dominant ins Spiel zu bringen. Also wie gesagt 4-3-3, mutig, die Außenverteidiger marschieren, auch ganz spannend finde ich er, ein Riesenverfechter davon. Seine zwei Außenstürmer ist immer, also auf links spielt ein Rechtsfuß und auf rechts ein Linksfuß. Er will, dass seine Außenangreifer torgefährlich ins Zentrum ziehen können, weil sie dadurch auch den Raum öffnen für die Außenverteidiger und die hinterlaufen fleißig, fleißig, fleißig und dann kommen die Achter auch da noch mit dazu vorne rein. Also wie gesagt, für ein Tina-Spiel kann man sich immer anschauen, weil da ist immer was los, das ist intensiv. Und deswegen auch Vincenzo Italiano, weil wir vorhin Thiago Motta hatten. Für mich auch ganz, ganz klar einer, der in den nächsten Jahren, was die italienischen Trainer betrifft, für mich wird der in einen sehr, sehr guten Weg gehen. Also ganz klar zu erkennen. Also wenn du ein für ein Tina-Spiel ansiehst, dann weißt du nach einer Viertelstunde oder 20 Minuten, was die wollen. Und das heißt aber nicht, dass die total dogmatisch sind, aber du siehst eine ganz klare Idee mit viel Intensität, viel Athletik, also auch ein europäischer, moderner Ansatz. Da bin ich mir sicher, dass Italiano seinen Weg gehen wird. Ich bin verwirrt, Christian. Ich bin ehrlich verwirrt. Ich dachte, es wird immer 1 zu 0 gespielt in Italien. Aber alles super defensiv und so weiter. Catenaccio ist ja auch nur ein Defensivsystem. Das kann man ausschließlich defensiv verstehen. Der Catenaccio hatte nichts mit Angreifen zu tun. Ach ist das schön. Ich mag die Ligatur. Diesen anderen Blick auf die Ligen. Aber wir sind jetzt am Ende dieser Ligatur angelangt. Es gibt nur noch die Matches to Watch natürlich, die ich abfragen muss. Jemand, der jetzt ganz lange nur passiver Zuhörer war, deswegen darf er jetzt als Erster sich melden. Jogi Hebel, was müssen wir in der Premier League unbedingt auf dem Schirm haben? Sowohl übertragungstechnisch als auch vom sportlichen her.
Ich würde sagen, Aston Villa gegen Newcastle wäre ein Spiel, das sehr interessant ist, weil Aston Villa jetzt so momentan unter Una Emery wieder richtig modern Fußball spielt und sich auf die Gegner einstellt. Und wie kaum ein zweites Team, die sind richtig am Kommen. Newcastle, wissen wir auch, die sind sehr, sehr unangenehm zu spielen. Sehr, sehr starke Defensive, die beste der Liga. Da bin ich echt gespannt, ob Aston Villa das so weitermachen kann. Die sind jetzt sechster, so richtig hochmarschiert. Das Spiel, würde ich sagen, dass so unterm Radar laufen wird, dass jetzt nicht jeder auf dem Schirm hat. Aber es ist 13.30 Uhr, es ist diese frühe Anstoßzeit, die der Engländer nicht so mag, die auf den asiatischen Markt abgestimmt ist. Aber ich glaube, das kann man sich schön anschauen. So mittagrum, schönes Fußballspiel, werde ich mir auf jeden Fall anschauen. Ich habe am Abend Manchester City, vielleicht ja auch fürs Rückspiel nochmal interessant, wie die sich gegen Leicester schlagen. Jetzt ja auch mit neuem Trainer, weil Dean Smith hier da übernommen hat, von Brandon Rogers. Und dann natürlich 15 Uhr am Sonntag Match of the Week mit den beiden Hebeln. Das kann ich nur empfehlen, auch um zu sehen, wie gut wir abonnieren.
Das werden wir sehen. West Ham gegen Arsenal, sollte man vielleicht nur dazu sagen, ist die Partie. Also am Rande wird es auch darum gehen.
Wir werden uns bemühen, da auch ein bisschen drüber zu sprechen.
Ja, sehr gut. Danke dir Jogi. Nils, was müssen wir in der Liga auf dem Schirm haben?
Ja, wenn ich eben schon den FC Valencia angesprochen habe, dann haben die auch jetzt wieder ein Abstiegsduell gegen den FC Sevilla im Mestalla. Das ist das, was sie in Hoffnung macht. Spannend auch, das baskische Derby der Athletik Club gegen Real Sociedad. Also in Bilbao, da steckt auch immer einiges an Geschichte und Nachwuchsarbeit dabei. Zwei ähnliche Vereine besonders. Und ich kann auch empfehlen, Real Madrid spielt in Cádiz. Ja, für Real Madrid geht es nicht immer um viel. Aber wenn man so in der Liga eine Auswärtsfahrt macht, dann am besten nach Cádiz, da freue ich mich schon drauf. Und das ist eben Samstag 21 Uhr, aber vielleicht am spannendsten Sonntagabend Valencia gegen Sevilla. Da geht es gegen den Abstieg.
Valencia gegen Sevilla. Was werden wir uns in der Ligue 1 zu Gemüte führen müssen, David?
Müssen? Lieber eben. Ach so, müssen im Sinne von must have, nicht?
Ja, natürlich, genau. Nein, das war jetzt nicht so, weil wir uns quälen. Meine Güte.
Sorry. Also jetzt Bezug nehmen wir auf das, was ich vorgestellt habe. Am Freitagabend kann man sich Toulouse gegen Lyon anschauen. Falls man bei Toulouse mal reinschauen will, dann kann man vielleicht auch mal achten auf Fares Shaibi, ein ganz spannender Spielmacher bei Toulouse, extrem variabel, der jetzt auch für die algerische Nationalelf berufen wurde. Samstag wäre die logische Antwort. Na ja, da spielt halt der Erste gegen den Zweiten, PSG gegen Lens, könnte ein Kracher-Spiel werden. Andererseits, wenn nicht, ja mein Gott, dann... Wenn Lens gewinnt, dann werden sie auf 3 Punkte ran. Da wäre es natürlich nochmal spannend, genau. Rennen gegen Rens ist ebenfalls am Samstag. Ich glaube aber, das wird nicht übertragen in Deutschland, wenn ich mich gerade richtig schnell informiert habe. Und natürlich ebenfalls Bezug nehmen auf das, was ich geschildert habe, die Woche drauf spielt Lens gegen Monaco. Und das wird tatsächlich für Monaco dann wiederum sehr, sehr wichtig, weil wenn die da wirklich nochmal oben heran kommen wollen auf ihre Champions League Plätze, auf denen sie sich ja eigentlich so ein bisschen sehen und wo sie zuletzt ja sehr, sehr unglücklich ausgeschieden sind in den letzten Jahren aus diversen Qualis, CL Qualis, dann wird das ein ganz, ganz wichtiges Spiel für Monaco, um da oben irgendwie nochmal einzugreifen.
Okay, ich sehe schon, wir werden viel Ligue 1 sehen und kaum noch Zeit haben, da irgendwas aus der Serie A mit reinzuquetschen. Wir wissen natürlich schon, Christian Bologna gegen Milan. Das ist am Samstag Nachmittag dieses Spiel. Gibt es noch was darüber hinaus? Ja, also Bologna-Milan, wie gesagt, eben sehr spannend, auch allein deshalb nicht nur wegen Thiago Motta und Bologna, sondern weil ja auch der Champions-League-Kampf sehr, sehr eng ist. Also Milan muss da schon auch schauen. Jetzt trotz, wir haben viel über Champions League jetzt und das besteht die Aussicht aus Halbfinale. Aber gerade beide Mailander-Clubs müssen in der Liga auch schauen, dass sie quasi die Champions-League-Quali über die Liga schaffen. Das ist sehr, sehr eng. Dementsprechend auch aus Milans Sicht sehr wichtig. Und wir haben am Montag dann Fiorentina gegen Atalanta zum Abschluss. Und wie gesagt, Atalanta auch immer noch in Reichweite, was Platz 4 betrifft, weil es eben so eng ist. Und die Fiorentina, die da auch versucht, eben jetzt noch mal da heranzuräumen. Wie gesagt, zwei haben wir, glaube ich, vorne mal angedeutet. Zwei der intensivsten Mannschaften auch in Italien. Also bei Fiorentina gegen Atalanta ist sicher einiges los. Und noch ein kleiner Blick auf die Woche drauf. Da ist dann Juve gegen Napoli. Das sollte man sich schon mal ankreiden. Da ist ja auch Napoli dann sozusagen die Champions-League-Nummer. Jetzt sage ich mal erst mal durch, das Viertelfinale. Vielleicht erinnere ich noch ein paar. Es gab im Januar dieses 5-1 von Napoli, das eigentlich so das Highlight-Spiel in der Liga auf dem Weg zu Jerms Colletto war, quasi wenn man auch die Rivalität zwischen Juve und Napoli kennt. Also da wird sicher einiges an Feuer drin sein. Das ist dann am Wochenende drauf. Ich mache mir mit dieser Ligatour komplett die Schlusskonferenzen zur Bundesliga kaputt. Aber ich kann da nichts dafür. Ich kann doch nichts dafür, Leute, wenn es überall sonst so spannend ist. Ich danke euch sehr für eure Zeit und dass ihr hier wart. Herzlichen Dank an Nils Kern. Danke, lieber Jogi Hebel. Schön, dass du wieder hier warst, David Frogier de Ponlevoy.
Danke schön, hat Spaß gemacht.
Wie flüssig mir das einfach inzwischen von den Lippen geht.
Ich liebe es.
Und danke, lieber Christian, dass du hier warst. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 257. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk finanziell. Rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Und indem wir uns weiterempfehlen an Freunden und Freunde, denen dieses Format und auch unsere anderen Formate gefallen könnte. Es gibt ja auch noch Tribüngespräche und die Schlusskonferenzen und so weiter und so fort. Es soll ein Medienimperium werden, der Rasenfunk. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bis bald hier wieder im Imperium. Macht's gut, ciao!